for more on gluten intolerance and the
problems it causes we are joined now by
dr. Reiner aurash he's a
gastroenterologist at the Charity
Hospital in Brennan thank you so much
for joining us here dr. Ulrich now what
you think of this report and the
research has just come out of minds is
it a game changer I think it is
definitely not a game changer for celiac
disease because nobody doubts that
cuteness the main factor in celiac
disease it may be a game changer if it
all comes true that gluten sensitivity
apart from celiac disease may be caused
by these 80 is what does it mean then
for people who are intolerant to gluten
if it is in fact true that it's 80 eyes
causing their problem and not gluten for
the celiacs nothing changes as i already
said for those with gluten sensitivity
it would be an explanation for their
symptoms but the therapy would all
anyway be the same you have to avoid
wheat and related great what's the main
difference between ati's and gluten
they're both proteins yes gluten is a
very important protein for wheat it just
leads to the consistence of bread and
nothing works without gluten it is just
as so sticky you know and this is a very
important for baking and all this in
contrast to this the ATIS are just there
to improve pest resistance for example
and we as consumers if we eat the food
we don't profit from the HD eyes and if
they harm us I think they should rather
be reduced absolutely now you yourself
are doing your own studies on gluten and
its problems for the human tract they'd
be indigestion tract can you tell us how
your studies either are similar or
different to the report that we've just
looked at it's a bit different because
look at non-celiac who have irritable
bowel syndrome which is a variety of
gastrointestinal symptoms for which we
do not know the cause at present and we
speculate that Rob new part of these
patients may profit from a routine free
diet and may be gluten sensitive also
they do not have celiac disease and this
report would fit very nicely because it
would could explain such symptoms in the
absence of celiac disease so there may
be actually something behind this report
now you are you seeing an increase in
people who are suffering from IBS celiac
disease and intolerance to gluten
there's definitely an increase in
diagonal celiac disease which is related
to much improved diagnostic methods we
have 15 years ago you had to get upper
endoscopy and biopsy to diagnose a
disease now you can just throw a blood
sample and look for antibodies so this
is much easier diagnosed and therefore
much more people are diagnosed with this
disease is this why we're seeing an
increase in gluten intolerant products
on the market place I'm not sure of that
I think a lot of this is just the hype
and you can sell anything if you write
on it it's free from whatever everybody
thinks this must be healthier for me
okay is it healthier oh maybe dr. Chopin
has its way it could be damned dr.
Ullrich thank you so much for joining us
here at tomorrow today nice
you